So the entry point for soft robotics can be rather inexpensive because,
again, it's casting with off-the-shelf rubbers.
At the same time, other aspects of robotics are also approachable.
The advent of the Arduino and all the things that made to
it is also making robotics become very, very egalitarian.
So I think that soft robotics,
just like many other fields of robotics,
are becoming accessible to everyone.
And it increases the amount to which you see inspiration in this world
because people have remarkable minds,
not just the ones who have access to resources to use them.
So lowering the barrier of entry means that more people on the planet are
contributing to our technology society and it's fantastic to see.
I was at an academic robotics conference a few weeks
back and a very substantial portion
of all the presentations had to do with soft robotics.
And why is this?
It's the fact that there are these insurmountable challenges in the field of
robots that people can't solve unless you start bringing in these compliant structures.
And as other people are starting to realize the power of using this platform technology,
they're starting to implement it in all manner of systems.
And I think that, as that understanding of the capabilities of soft robotics grows,
the implementation will grow,
and you'll start seeing more and more of it in robotic systems to the point where
in a little while from now I kind
of feel like people won't think twice about seeing soft robotics.
It will just be robotics where that soft part was the coolest part.
I'm most excited about human-robotic interaction.
So you take a look at collaborative robotics and a lot of great people have
taken the approach of taking systems that are made out of metal, that move fast,
that have a lot of aspects of them that are
fundamentally dangerous and through good software and good sensing,
building systems that could lower the level of threat from the device.
So there are a lot of interesting areas of soft robotics that are being explored so.
As I said before soft robotics,
think of it as not just the actuators but the sensors and
both are being researched in interesting application spaces.
So if you think about the soft actuators side of it,
and going back to human-robot interactions,
there are people who are building a mechanical kind of heart-assist devices.
So imagine an LVAD that cups under the heart and can compress the heart and pump blood.
That's remarkable.
You have the ability to circulate blood through the body
for someone whose heart isn't working in a way where
the mechanical parts never actually make blood contact which
is actually a very substantial improvement to the quality of someone's health.
So that's a human-robotic mechanical interaction.
Another example of that is you probably have seen a whole bunch
of robot, soft robotic hands.
Where actuators are laid on the back of a hand and allow
you to either a, do rehab exercises.
I myself once hurt my hand and I had to do rehab exercises.
They're very boring. You kind of never actually do
them unless you're at your physical therapist's office
and then they yell at you for not doing them.
So imagine a glove that you could bring home and it was simple to use.
It kind of wasn't an inconvenience so,
you had a higher rate of patient compliance by using this system.
Which means a lower chance of kind of surgical revision of
whatever was done to mend you because you're complying with your treatment.
You have the capacity to take
the soft mechanical structure and incorporate it with something that's more engaging than
physical therapy like a videogame that tracks
your progress and kind of rewards you for good behavior.
So that's the sort of,
doing that with a soft structure is a lot more plausible than a hard structure.
And on the far end of it,
by using fundamental soft actuator technology you have healthier people.
So that's very interesting.
There's also the soft robotic sensor sign which you can see in wearables, right?
Right now wearables predominantly focus on sports applications,
and those are those are fun and great applications,
but you know skinning people's bodies with sensors
could have a lot of meaning for society for example,
the world's population is aging.
You take a look at all across Europe and all across
North America and China and Japan, you name it.
There's this inverted population where everyone is towards the side,
the elder side of the spectrum where they need care.
And part of that care is understanding what's going on in a person's body,
and we don't have enough people to do all that work.
So you know using soft compliant sensing structures to monitor someone's health,
provide you real time warnings when something horrible has happened,
I think that's a wonderful application.
Actually also brings us back to mechanical soft robotic wearables where
something like the rehab glove I just described could
also be an exoskeleton that allows you to keep living
your life long after you may not have the full physical capability of doing so.
So when I think of outside of the gripping solutions that we
deliver here of great places that soft robotics need to be,
I think of wearable robotics.